similar to nationalism
isn't racism and expression of tribalism
given the evolved nature of tribalism is
there any hope of truly overcoming these
divisions and uniting the world or are
we doomed to petty sectarianism oh
wonderful question
um you are right
people don't like this but you're right
that racism
is an expression of what i would call
lineage selection
why anyone thinks otherwise i don't know
we've talked ourselves in circles around
this for
no reason it's actually a
straightforward matter
however your concerns in the second part
of your question i don't believe
are well-founded in fact i think we know
that they are not because if you build a
system
in which collaboration with people to
whom you are not closely related
is profitable then people
engage it willingly and we see this and
the profit isn't inherently monetary
i mean it in the in a much more general
sense so
um yes the secular pluralistic
cosmopolitan west
is really a demonstration of this which
doesn't mean that we ever fully achieved
it
but it does mean that all of the things
that we have done that have
rendered things like race and sex
secondary
in terms of where they fall on people's
you know schema of considerations
has been wildly productive right we have
all profited from
putting these things as uh secondary or
better non-important considerations and
um the answer has it remains
to keep going down this road the farther
we go in this direction the more we look
past these things
in order to achieve what we're trying to
accomplish
the better we do um and this is why some
of us
are uh you know um so troubled by this
woke revolution is that it is
threatening to
undo the progress that we've made to
cause us to forget what the objective
was and why it was a good thing and
frankly
you know it's going to return us to a
prior state of history that was
much worse